so wait we both grew up during the 80s
so what were your favorite parts of the
decade did you love the music
man i love the music man we used to have
a a a show that came on friday night in
indiana called night tracks and they
played all eight with an x a night
yeah yeah they played man they played uh
uh bruce springsteen they flowed played
uh uh
uh uh what's her name uh grace jones
yeah yeah i got introduced to a lot of
music from the 80s that you know it's
like yeah 80s music was the best i feel
like too like radio was more broad like
you could hear like so many different
kinds of artists on one station yeah
yeah i like that british music i love it
that's why people like you know a lot of
my black friend they're like man how you
know all this
white music night tracks
night tracks night tracks with an x yeah
yeah yeah they knew what was that's a
rhinestone cowboy yeah exactly
i know that i know but you know that and
grace jones and bruce springsteen
they're all on the same channel that's
amazing and i know poo scheiste you ever
heard of food
that sounds like something else it's a
wrap
sounds like something else maybe it's a
different name where you grow up i don't
know um
it's a family show sorry i took it there
[Music]
you